[music]
>> In the late 560s, a Germanic group known
as the Lombards was wrecking havoc
through northern Italy. To escape the
invaders, boatloads of people fled into
the Venetian Lagoon, a morass of swampy
mudflats and scattered islands. Formed
over centuries by the outflow of silt
from the Po and Piave rivers and the
counterforce of Adriatic currents, this
marshy maze was constantly shifting and
disappearing. These qualities made it
both the perfect [music] spot to hide
and a very unstable place to live.
So, the new arrivals set out to tame the
lagoon and build the most unlikely of
cities from the mud.
While some fishermen already inhabited
the region [music] in stilted huts, the
settlers wanted to build a foundation to
support heavier, longer-lasting
structures. Little did they know their
work would support Venice to this very
day.
They drove clusters of 1 to 3 [music] m
long wooden piles into the ground in a
process that squeezed out groundwater
and compacted [music] mud around the
piles.
This created an oxygen-free environment
that protected the wood from insects and
fungi. [music]
The piles were still vulnerable to minor
bacterial damage, but otherwise
impervious to rot. And this sealed
system of wood, water,
>> [music]
>> and mud is still supporting Venice 1,500
years [music] later.
Wooden beams and stone platforms above
the piles provided the basis for
buildings. And sometime around 697,
the settlers formally declared their new
home the Republic of Venice.
Initially, footbridges were built to
connect the islands, but these were
prone to decay, collapse, and fire.
Many, like the famed Rialto Bridge, had
to be regularly rebuilt, each time
incorporating new materials and
techniques to improve their longevity.
By the 11th century, the channels
between islands had been reinforced into
stone-lined canals navigated by slender
gondolas.
And unlike the rest of Europe, where
nobles typically rode above commoners,
the city's layout necessitated foot
travel for all classes. Yet, despite
this clever engineering, the Republic
still had no land for farming. So,
Venetians were heavily dependent on
trade. Fortunately, Venice's location
made it the perfect port city
>> [music]
>> to connect markets from Europe to the
Silk Road. Its canal network allowed
boats to dock close to warehouses, and
the challenge of navigating its [music]
narrow waterways protected the city from
outsiders.
These advantages helped make Venice a
major maritime power, and the 1200s
began with their biggest business
[music] deal yet.
The Pope brokered an arrangement with
Venice's elected leader, Enrico Dandolo,
to produce ships and arms for the Fourth
Crusade's [music] anticipated 33,000
soldiers. Dandolo agreed, investing huge
amounts of the Republic's money and
resources.
But when it was [music] time to set
sail, only 1/3 of the soldiers arrived
with less than half of the promised
payment.
Furious,
>> [music]
>> Dandolo redirected the crusading army
against Venice's Christian rivals,
including Constantinople. This campaign
laid the foundation for Venice's
overseas empire, and over the following
centuries, Venetian merchants like Marco
Polo ventured as far as China. During
the Renaissance, the Republic became a
hub of art and intellectual [music]
life. Its sail-making looms were
repurposed to create vast [music]
canvases. Its craftsmen pioneered
various printing techniques, and the
silica-rich sands [music]
from the Ticino and Adige rivers fueled
extravagant glassworks.
However, in addition to art, silks, and
spices, the Venetians also traded
enslaved peoples to work in private
homes or on ships. Once freed, some
stayed in the city, even finding work as
gondoliers.
Venice's dominance over the
Mediterranean remained unchallenged
until the mid-15th century, when the
Ottomans conquered Constantinople. In
the following centuries, the Ottomans
used their navy to interfere with
Venice's business, all while new
transoceanic [music]
trade routes excluded Venetians.
The Republic soldiered on until French
attacks [music]
forced it to dissolve in 1797,
at which point Venice traded hands
between Austria and France several times
before finally being ceded to Italy
[music] in 1866.
No longer able to compete commercially,
Venice was reinvented as a tourist
destination. But today, rising sea
levels are threatening to sink the
so-called floating city. In 1900, the
then 900-year-old
Basilica di San Marco flooded about
seven times [music] a year. Now, it
experiences roughly 250
annual floods.
And tourists are perhaps just as
dangerous. As millions of annual
visitors speed along in motorboats,
[music] they erode the muddy barrier
protecting Venice's foundations. Left
unaddressed, [music] these modern
advances could destroy one of the
world's most remarkable cities.
If you enjoy learning about history,
subscribe to this channel
because the lessons of yesterday can
help us face the challenges of today.
>> [music]